I will never use the metric system. At least
that's the title of the video I just made.
Every time I make a video, there are loads of
things that don't make it in. There’s just too
much information out there. I mean, look at
this. So here are five things that didn't make
the cut. The word “jiffy” is an actual unit.
It's the equivalent of approximately 1/60th of
a second. Be there in a jiffy! Napoleon isn't
actually short like everyone says he is. He was
just mismeasured because he was the guy who
was around while the metric system was sort
of being adopted by France and there was just
a misconversion, blah blah blah. Because the
United States teaches both imperial and a little
bit of metric in school, it is estimated that
a full year of math instruction is lost to the
duplicated efforts of learning both metric and
imperial. Sad sad sad. Which is why the United
States ranks 38th out of 71 countries in terms
of math skills. There is a freeway in America
that only uses metric signs. Look at this. I
went really deep into the whole story as to why
this all went down. It is pretty fascinating
and at the end of the day, kind of sad. I
wish I used the metric system, but I can't.